all right 2018 s coming to a close can
you believe it so we thought what better
time then to highlight a few of the
media lowlights from the past year and
our friends at gray vien helped us out
here to my old producer Tom Elliot does
a great job they're here with me now to
take us through the tape former Arkansas
governor Mike Huckabee hosted media buzz
also right here on Fox News Howie Kurtz
all right gents I want to first start
with the media's once warm embrace of a
man who is now not on the top of the
invite list let's watch
stormy dangers lawyer Michael avenatti
joins us live now it's joining me now is
stormy Daniels attorney Michael avenatti
Michael avenatti is with us now
Michael empanada joins us now and
joining me now from Los Angeles is
Michael avenatti we want more of the
spooning comments that they made toward
avenatti Howie
it was hard to book yeah he was the
belle of the ball though until he wasn't
so should the media have seen this
coming with the meltdown of amun-re the
degree that would CNN MSNBC put this guy
on sometimes several times a day to
peddle his unsubstantiated claims and
develop his presidential delusions was
really something but the worst by far
was putting on avenatti to make the
claims of the Julie sweat Nick to vouch
for this woman who accused Brett
Kavanaugh of being in a bunch of gang so
we want to see tell us more that's what
got the introduction we might see that
it's like oh really tell us more about
all the sons of Stan she ate of garbage
that should go down is one of the
biggest black eyes of this media over
the last 12 months without disgusting
and do we go to the next one now
all right well Huck wants to describe
this as well well governor I think
Michael avenatti is just one of those
figures who will occasionally pop up on
like if they have a you know celebrity
Hollywood Squares maybe you know he'll
he'll be the right the lower right
square or something but I don't know I
don't see avenatti having playing much
of a role and public life in the future
well I think his his history is up like
a rocket down like a rock back under the
rock from when she crawled that's the
end of the story for Michael either
Nadya I'm pretty sure all right
number two
our list involves some actual dumpster
diving as journalists attempt to find
some dirt literally tying President
Trump to Russia quickly you look through
the trash there what did you find
yes we did well we came here expecting
this office to be to be empty but in
fact all day and here we've been here
throughout the course of the day people
have been going in and out we went to
the trash can to see what we could find
saw people dumping rubbish their new
computers new computers are being
delivered here and they're throwing away
the rubbish well if somehow the accent
makes it all the more yeah with the
rubbish let's inspect the rubbish not
that big a deal but it kind of smells
well yeah literally and figuratively but
governor again this does it just tells
you how low they can go I mean going
through the garbage now I mean I guess
you can do that but for what what they
get I thought they were I thought they
were doing a tour of their newsroom
because that's what we typically see
with a lot of these networks I mean
anything anything and that does show
that if you're willing to go through
people's trash hoping to get something
negative on conservatives you're pretty
desperate and this is a media that's
pretty desperate there's no doubt about
that what's it what's the rating for the
media now because their approval rating
is so usually the hovers around 20% or
something
whether people respect them maybe up to
30 but basically up to 30 now wow that's
actually pretty no this is not my rating
I'm talking shows up yeah God what do
you do like Google search or even for
high but this isn't really 3rd I've just
got to tell you Howie the flu is more
popular than the media right now well it
is on the downward spiral and some of
these examples show why people don't
trust the press all right let's move on
where some CNN hosts did their best to
test the limits of the FCC it's the
craziest I ever heard whole country's
whole country these countries are holes
I couldn't give about them I've
definitely been you
slopers and slant-eyes called you and
i'm gonna [ __ ] it they didn't say the
wear out the beeper there I don't even
know how you do those edits on that
stuff governor let's start with you
the swear fest I mean I guess it's
people are more authentic living their
truth I love that phrase we're living
our truth by I didn't like going our
previous guests who it was a war hero
and triple amputee I mean I adore him I
don't like it when people use yeah yes
SED on-air I know that sound like
old-fashioned but I know we all swear I
mean maybe not governor elsewhere but we
kind of want to not on TV as much if we
can possibly not well I don't know if
you notice they're not but that they
quit serving sandwiches in the CNN
cafeteria and now they just sell soap
for the people to eat that because
they've gotten so potty mouth on that
soap yeah in one interview CNN anchor
Fareed Zakaria called Trump abs are
using the forward for different times it
just goes to show that when you're
talking about Donald Trump the standards
go out the window there's a complete
double standard you can get down and
dirty and curse all you want because
somehow that's so I mean there's also we
have anchors he's a race to see the race
I mean just like he's at races he's a
liar he's a blanking racist he's a
blanket racist but I mean it's just it
shows you both governor and Howie
it shows you and I hate the patron
derangement syndrome has become such a
cliche but it's something is burrowed
deep into the psyche of people that
they're not even able to have
friendships with people with whom they
disagree the tolerance set and this you
see this in media figures people who
I've been friends with in other media
outlets for years not all of them but I
used to like Don Lemon Don Lemon used to
come on my radio show we were joking
earlier the ice have people like Frank
Rich on my radio John Kerry like we can
disagree but now they're so there is
some it's burrowed in anger and
resentment and upset men at Katyn frat
or no have a conversation like you're a
horrible awful rotten person if you ever
said anything nice about Donald Trump
and it's and it's using out of their
pores which is very strange all right
the last one on our list is someone I
just mentioned CNN's Don Lemon
describing the biggest terror threat
facing our country right now we have to
stop demonizing people and realize the
biggest terror threat in this country is
white men most of them radicalized right
up to the right and we have to start
doing something about them there is no
travel ban on them
there's no ban on you know they have the
Muslim ban there is no white guy ban so
what do we do about that
governor Huckabee what do we do one of
those em what do we do white man so yeah
you know I'm guilty as charged I am an
American white man and I don't know what
Donnellan is gonna do what is he gonna
do to deport me to where I'm an American
born citizen what is he gonna do arrest
me for what I think differently than him
this is America this is really that the
height of it but I got to tell you
Laurie it's not just what he says it's
that tone where he's attempting so
diligently to sound authoritative that I
found beyond amusing and these guys who
sit and they pontificate night after
night with such a tone of seriousness as
if they are personally saving this great
Republic pain to have to say that having
having this before we go remember this
ad from CNN this is a whole bunch of
bananas
somewhere buried within it is an apple
some people might try to tell you that
there's no point in looking for it but
there's only one way to know what's been
covered up you start digging
move over James Earl Jones I like James
Earl Jones better this is CNN this is
CNN don't slip on the banana peel kind
of a fruitcake ad ya know but there is a
certain self-righteousness that has
creeped into a lot of media self-motion
Washington Post democracies and the
doctors somehow democracy wasn't in
danger small business might die in the
face of I'm all for self-promotion but
let's keep it real well
still to come both of you thank you so
much